منكوبه هي تلك الولايات التركيه التي
ضربها زلزال كهرمان مراش بتاريخها
وعمرانها وطرق كسب اهلها وقبل ذلك واهم
منه باهلها انفسهم من مات منهم ومن نجا
تقرب صوره الدمار وتداعياته على الاتراك
في تلك الولايات ما احصته مبدئيا مديريه
شؤون البناء التابعه لوزاره البيئه
التركيه
فماذا تقول الجرده حساب احصت نحو 35% فقط
من الاضرار التي لحقت بالولايه العشر التي
ضربها الزلزال في تلك الولايات
7,619 بناء يجب هدمها بشكل عاجل ويتضاعف
الرقم في الابنيه التي اصيبت بضرر كبير
الى
12,705 وتشمل هذه الاحصائيه البيوت
والمكاتب والمؤسسات التجاريه
بنظره سريعه تبدو ولايه غازي عنتاب
وهاتايا صاحبه الارقام الكبرى حتى الان من
تلك الابنيه الواجب هدمها بسرعه عوده
الضرر الكبير الولايات الثلاث اي غازي
عنتاب وهاتاي وملاطي على سبيل المثال
يقطنها وفق الاحصاءات الرسميه اكثر من
اربعه ملايين تركي يضاف لهم نحو
كثير من هؤلاء خياراتهم ضئيله ومحصوره
باتجاه ترك مناطقهم ولو مؤقتا والتوجه الى
ولايات اخرى بحثا عن السكن واستمرار
الاعمال والتعليم وغير ذلك هذه الارقام
الاوليه قد تفسر وتقرب ما كان ذكره الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في وقت سابق بان
المتضررين في المناطق المنكوبه ومحيطها قد
يصلون الى نحو 20 مليون مواطن تركي